so we've just started the new year or
what 18 days in you might be looking at
some goals to try and get your finances
in order yeah right how you doing time
to check in
it is though it's hard for so many
especially for so many in our city who
are still unemployed bianca holman live
with some advice from a financial expert
bianca good morning
good morning so
we know that it's the top of the year
it's a great time to take a look at your
financial situation and possibly make
some adjustments so the number one tip
we got was budget yes budget budget
budget i know we hear it all the time
but it's a tried and true way to meet
your financial goals and save so we
checked in with the financial expert and
of course they recommend take a look
back at your finances from the previous
year where did you spend the most what
unexpected expenses came up this can
help you set up a baseline for this
year's budget
next set your new goals is it to save
more purchase a home a car build
emergency expenses or even long-term
goals like college tuition we spoke with
two people who participated in budgeting
workshops with groups like goodwill and
help of southern nevada they both say
sticking to a budget has made a huge
difference
with my budgeting now it has definitely
allowed me to become more aware
and i'm like an automatic calculator the
second i hear about something i'm
constantly breaking it down between
paycheck and paycheck days to weeks
and we also heard from a woman with help
of southern nevada she says that she has
learned to reuse recycle and she now
knows where every penny is going and
then also we just heard from andre
robinson he participated in goodwill's
personal financial literacy program and
he says ask for help and don't be afraid
to make some changes if you need to and
there of course some free apps like
every dollar that's by the ramsey
organization and that is free you can
help you set up a budget and also coming
up in the next half hour we're going to
talk about some new tax laws that you
could benefit from possibly coming up in
april reporting live bianca holman live
local now